live life on easy mode so we just want
to keep I don't think I don't think
that's true I think I think women
struggle just as much as men do you
think a woman so one of the number one I
think no but I think the struggles are
different yeah but we struggle just the
same so you think a secretary is
struggling just as much as a coal miner
you think those are equal struggles but
a secretary could be a man and a coal
miner could also be a woman like they
could be they're both women are the
majority of secretaries men are the
majority of coal miners and I could do
10 different examples that are really
similar plumber electrician construction
worker garbage men all men